This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I was working at the radio station K-A-L-W in San Francisco in 2003 when a preview copy of the book, Stiff, The Curious Lives of Human Cadhavers, was sent to the station. It immediately became one of my favorite books of all time, full of fun, gruesome, intriguing stories about what happens to our bodies after we die. So, in 2003, I scheduled what turned out to be the very very, first media interview of the author, Mary Roach.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。2003年，我在旧金山的KALW广播电台工作时，电台收到了一本新书的预读本——《僵硬：人类尸体的奇异生活》。这本书立刻成了我这辈子最喜欢的书之一，里面充满了有趣、可怕又引人入胜的故事，讲述了我们死后身体会发生什么。所以在2003年，我安排了对这本书的作者玛丽·罗奇的采访，这后来成了她人生中的第一次媒体采访。
Do you remember that? I remember it so well. I was like, oh, I got it, and I kind of dressed up, even though it's radio. It was like one of the best interviews ever. Over the years, Mary and I have become friends. We even shared an office in Oakland for a while. And over her career, she has continued to come out with some of the best and certainly the funniest science books I've ever read.
你还记得吗？我记得太清楚了。当时我想，哦，我拿到了，我还特意盛装打扮了一番，尽管这只是个广播节目。那绝对是有史以来最好的采访之一。这些年来，玛丽和我成了朋友。我们甚至在奥克兰合租过一段时间办公室。在她的职业生涯中，她不断推出一些我读过最好、当然也最搞笑的科普书。
Longtime listeners will know that she has been on the show. a few times over the years, but when she announced that her new book was about designing human replacement parts, designing is the key word there, I knew that it was time for us to have a long overdue chat. My name is Mary Roach, and my book is called Replacable You, and the subtitle, which doesn't really tell you that much, is Adventures in Human Anatomy. But what it really is, is this scientific pursuit to find replacement parts for our worn-out diseased and malfunctioning bodies.
老听众都知道，这些年来她曾多次做客本节目。但当她宣布新书的主题是设计人类替换部件时——“设计”是其中的关键词——我知道我们是时候进行一次早就该进行的畅谈了。我的名字叫玛丽·罗奇，我的书名叫《可替代的你》，副标题其实没透露太多，叫《人体解剖学历险记》。但它真正的内容是，这是一场科学探索，旨在为我们磨损、生病和发生故障的身体寻找替换部件。
That is exactly right. Some of it historical and some of it current. Yeah, just these efforts to swap things out, make things from scratch, grow things from scratch, all those things we want to do and sometimes do, do. I said do, do do. And, you know, what struck me, you know, as I was reading this book and, you know, like we're a design show ostensibly, is that, you know, you know, this is the mother of all design problems. Like, there are really major roadblocks to designing replacement parts for the human body. It is, like, truly difficult.
完全正确。其中一部分是历史，一部分是现实。是的，就是这些努力：把东西换掉、从零开始制造、从零开始培育，所有这些我们想要做、有时也会做的事情。我说“做做”事情。你知道，当我读这本书时，让我感到震撼的是——你知道，我们明面上是一个设计节目——这就是所有设计问题的鼻祖。也就是说，为人体设计替换部件确实存在着重大的阻碍。这简直太难了。
Could you just talk about why that is? Yeah, I mean, the basic problem here is that you have 200 years, more or less, of medicine and engineering that's trying to compete with millions of years of evolutionary tinkering. And that's tough to do. And the other thing is that just things that seem simple are not in the human body. There's nothing simple. One idea that you present in the book is that we have somewhat worked out how to replace simple organ functions in the body with these big external machines like dialysis for kidney function or a big ECMO machine, which takes over the function of the heart and lungs. But the holy grail for replacement human parts are organic, maybe donated, maybe animal-grown parts that can be surgically implanted into a person whose body is damaged. Why is that last step of integrating replacement parts into the body so difficult?
你能谈谈为什么会这样吗？是的，我的意思是，这里面的基本问题是，你有两百年左右的医学和工程学历史，正试图与数百万年的进化修补术竞争。这很难做到。另一个问题是，在人体中，看似简单的事情其实并不简单。没有什么事情是简单的。你在书中提出的一个观点是，我们已经某种程度上解决了用大型外部机器替换体内简单器官功能的问题，比如用于肾功能的透析，或者接管心肺功能的大型ECMO机器。但人类替换部件的圣杯是有机的、也许是捐赠的、也许是动物培育的部件，可以外科手术式地植入身体受损的人体内。为什么将替换部件整合到体内的最后一步会如此困难？
Yeah, and it comes down, I think, to two very basic features of the human body, and one is the immune system. You know, when you're developing a machine outside the body, the immune system. doesn't give a shit. Yeah. You try to stick that in. And now you've got the immune system. For one, you've also have to deal with clotting. You know, if you've got like a stent in there, you know, anytime the blood's sort of coursing along through the blood vessels, and as long as what it's touching is the wall of a blood vessel, it's fine.
是的，我认为这归结为人类身体的两个非常基本的特征，其中一个是免疫系统。你知道，当你在体外开发一台机器时，免疫系统根本不在乎。是的。你试图把它塞进去。现在你就要面对免疫系统了。首先，你还得处理凝血问题。你知道，如果你体内有一个支架，你知道，任何时候血液沿着血管奔涌，只要它接触到的是血管壁，那就没问题。
But if it starts, if there's something else there, it's like, ugh, and it starts to form clots. So people with stents and things in the body often have to. be on blood thinners and so there's that going on and then just the body can have a sort of an inflammatory reaction and that can just become a mess and infection that's another thing anytime you open up the body and you put in something from the outside world it's really hard to be 100% sure that you're not letting in bacteria and infection inside the body body is a real bitch. When a hip replacement or a knee replacement goes poorly, it's almost always infection. Yeah. And that's, and that, you know, if you're using a cane, you're not going to have to
但如果它开始，如果有其他东西在那里，它就会觉得“呃”，然后开始形成血栓。所以体内有支架和其他东西的人经常必须服用血液稀释剂，所以会有这些情况发生；然后身体还可能会产生一种炎症反应，这可能会变得一团糟；还有感染，那是另一回事。任何时候只要你打开身体，放入外来的东西，就很难百分之百确保没有让细菌和感染进入体内。身体真是一个彻头彻尾的混蛋。当髋关节置换或膝关节置换手术失败时，几乎总是因为感染。是的。而且，如果你用的是手杖，你就不用
worry about infection. I guess that's right. Well, what do you think that impulse is for replacement function to be further and further integrated into the body? Like, for example, when someone is very ill and their heart and lungs can't function. A big ecmo machine will pump the blood out and oxygenated in the machine and then pump the blood back in. And it works amazingly well. Like someone could be on an ecmo machine forever, I suppose. And if someone wanted to live a more normal life where they could walk around and do things, you could go down the path of designing you know, a smaller and smaller ECMO machine. But even the man who invented the ECMO machine decades ago, is now trying to find ways to make donated hearts better and more successful for
担心感染了。我想是这样的。嗯，你认为那种追求让替换功能更深入地整合到体内的冲动是从何而来的？比如说，当某人重病且心肺功能无法运作时，一台大型ECMO机会把血抽出来，在机器里充氧，然后再把血泵回去。它的运作效果惊人。我想，一个人甚至可以永远靠ECMO机器活着。如果有人想过上更正常的生活，可以四处走动并做一些事情，你可能会走上这样一条道路：设计越来越小的ECMO机器。但甚至几十年前发明ECMO机器的那个人，现在也在努力寻找方法，让捐赠的心脏变得更好，并在
transplants. How did that preference for finding solutions that were more and more organic, more and more natural, strike you as you were doing your research? Yeah, there's definitely a bias for wholeness and for normalness, and I'm using quotes around normal. Yeah, yeah. What is normal? But, you know, we all know it when we see it. And you go out and the world wheeling a portable ecmo machine and first of all it's going into your body and yeah okay they can probably finesse it so it's less dramatic but it's kind of like these two vampiric if that's an adjective opening you know in the in the neck you know so and and uh you're you're canulated in other words it's like it's going one tube is going into the other if you trip and fall you're
移植中取得更大的成功。当你做研究时，这种对寻找越来越有机、越来越自然解决方案的偏好给你留下了什么印象？是的，这里面绝对存在对完整性和“正常性”的偏好，我给“正常”加上了引号。对，对。什么是正常？但是，你知道，我们每个人一眼就能看出来。你推着一台便携式ECMO机器走在世界上，首先，它要进入你的身体，好吧，他们也许能处理得让它不那么戏剧化，但这有点像这两个吸血鬼般的（如果这是一个形容词的话）开口，你知道的，在脖子上，所以，呃，你是被插管的，换句话说，就像一根管子插进另一根里。如果你绊倒了，你
gonna decanulate and that's like blood's burning everywhere you got like you know a couple minutes and you're dead well yeah going fast forward i don't know 30 years maybe yeah this could be done in one of the in like a little pouch that you wear in a fanny pack i don't know but it's still not you yeah and it's still you'd just rather have something inside you you you know you'd rather be able to pass as just human and there's such a bias for it that it's really hard for people with underperforming limbs, feet, say. You know, I spent some time with a woman who, it took her a long time, but she succeeded in getting her own foot amputated
就会拔管，那就像鲜血四溅，你只有几分钟时间，然后你就死定了。好吧，是的，快进到，我不知道，30年后，也许吧，这可以在一个小袋子里完成，就像你戴在腰包里的那种，我不知道，但那仍然不是你，对吧？而且你宁愿有什么东西在你体内，你知道，你宁愿能够伪装得就像个普通人，而且这种偏好如此强烈，以至于那些肢体、足部功能不佳的人真的很难过。你知道，我和一个女人相处了一段时间，她花了很长时间，但她成功切除了自己的脚，
even though it was healthy. It was healthy, it was viable, but it was underperforming. It was twisted. But it was clear to her watching people with a prosthetic foot, especially below the knee, pretty simple thing to replace, really, in terms of prosthetics. And she'd see those people running and hiking and just sort of living life the way most people do. And she couldn't do any of that.
尽管它很健康。它很健康，很有活力，但它的功能不佳。它是扭曲的。但她看着戴着假肢（尤其是膝盖以下的假肢，就假肢而言其实是一个相当简单的东西）的人们，发现他们能奔跑、远足，就像大多数人一样生活，而她什么也做不了。
And yet surgeons were like, nope, not taken off this foot, perfectly healthy foot. And, yeah, as in oxygenated, you know, nothing's dead on it. But it didn't work, you know. And there was a guy who had foot drop, which is, you know, when you're walking, you need to pick your toes up. and then put them down and you do it automatically but some people have nerve with Parkinson's I think too
然而外科医生们的态度却是：不，不能切掉这只脚，这是一只完全健康的脚。而且，是的，血液含氧充足，你知道，上面没有任何东西是坏的。但它就是不好用，你知道。还有一个人患有足下垂，也就是走路时你需要把脚趾抬起来，
so you end up kind of shuffling and he didn't want to do that he's like give me a prosthetic foot and so he shot himself in the foot and that way they couldn't say you have a perfectly healthy foot here like you have a mangled mess we will take it off
然后再放下，你本能地会自动这样做，但有些人神经有问题，我想帕金森患者也是这样，
yeah we've mentioned the fact that a lot of the integration of replacement parts is particularly difficult Could you name some examples of where it's actually kind of worked well? Sure. I would say a couple of success stories. And one of them I don't actually talk about in this book. I talked about it in Gulp.
所以你最后只能拖着脚走路，而他不想那样。他说：“给我装个假肢吧。”于是他朝自己的脚开了一枪，这样他们就不能说“你这里有一只完全健康的脚”了，而是会说“你这有一团烂肉，我们会把它切掉”。
And that's the fecal microbiome transplant, which is to take somebody else's gut bacteria and put it in your own. Just replace the microbiome. and that works really well, particularly with people who have an infection with C. diff, C. difficil, which is a really serious gut infection that kills, I don't have the numbers, but it's kind of astounding. So you, in back in the day, before they sort of isolated the bacteria and put them in a capsule, you're talking about some guy coming in with a brown paper bag and handing it over going, yeah, not my best effort, but that you take that. It's like shit. You put it. it in a blender, an oyster blender, actually, and you, the guy's taking some antibiotics to get kind of a clean slate. You use a colonoscope, which has a spurting function, and you just put it up there. And within two days, I mean, the patient that I saw two days later, he's having what they say
是的，我们提到过，许多替换部件的整合特别困难。你能说出一些其实运作得挺不错的例子吗？当然可以。我想说有几个成功案例。其中一个我实际上在这本书里没有谈到。我在《吞咽》里谈过它。
on the Bristol stool scale, number three, I think, smooth and soft like a sausage or snake. And it's like, it was on Saturday night. He'd had the surgery like Thursday, and on Saturday night, that's what he sent to the physician. I mean, that's not everybody's idea of a great Saturday night, but that, for him, was the best Saturday night ever. And that's a simple, just take it out and put it in. I mean, now it's done with expensive capsules, yada, yada. But that works. The other one that is really pretty amazing is intraocular lenses,
那就是粪便微生物群移植，也就是把别人的肠道细菌放进你自己的体内。只需更换微生物群，这非常管用，特别是对于感染了艰难梭菌（C. diff, C. difficile）的人，这是一种非常严重的肠道感染，会导致死亡——我没有具体数字，但相当惊人。所以你，在过去，在他们把细菌分离并放进胶囊之前，你会看到某个家伙拿着一个棕色纸袋走进来，交出来说：“是的，这不是我最好的水平，但你拿去吧。”就像屎一样。你把它
for cataracts. I definitely want to talk about this. My wife has had terrible vision her entire life, recently had cataract surgery and had lens replaced. And it is life-changing for her. Yeah. Yeah. It's so much so that there are people in their 20s
放进搅拌机里——实际上是一个生蚝搅拌机，然后，病人吃了一些抗生素来获得一张干净的石板。你用一个带喷射功能的结肠镜，把它塞进去。两天之内，我是说，我两天后看到的那个病人，他的大便就像他们在
who are extremely near-sighted. And for whatever reason, contacts aren't comfortable. They don't want to do LASIC. They're asking to just have the lens popped out in a new one put in. Like they don't have cataracts, but they don't have cataracts. They don't have cataracts. It's just they want, they want that miraculous vision that you get with these lenses. So a cataract, it's kind of confusing because people think it's a separate thing from the lens. But the lens, as you age, it gets cloudy and dark and hard. And it's, the whole lens is referred to as the cataract. And they take the whole thing out and put in a new, clear, lovely man-made, lens that has been but you know that didn't happen overnight you know back in the 60s that was like a you were in the hospital for eight days it was a big incision with stitches people would lie in bed with
布里斯托大便分类法上说的，第三型，我想，像香肠或蛇一样光滑柔软。那是星期六晚上。他大概是星期四做的手术，星期六晚上，这就是他发给医生的东西。我的意思是不是每个人都觉得那是美妙的星期六晚上，但对他来说，那是史上最棒的星期六晚上。这是一个简单的“拿出来放进去”的过程。我的意思是，现在它是用昂贵的胶囊来完成的，等等等等。但确实管用。另一个非常惊人的例子是眼内晶状体，
sandbags holding their head in place uh there it didn't often go well they would not let people get it till they were a lot older because they they wanted to wait till your vision is so bad that you're going to be grateful for even a small improvement yeah but now it's uh um yeah people are happier with it than they were before. Yeah. And in the book, you actually travel to Mongolia to folks that are encouraging cataract surgery to folks who live out in the plains and therefore have, I guess, sort of damaged eyes from the sun in particular in trying to sort of encourage them to, that this procedure
用于治疗白内障。我非常想聊聊这个。我妻子一辈子视力都很差，最近做了白内障手术并更换了晶状体。这对她来说是改变人生的一件事。是的。是的。以至于现在有些20多岁的人，
is like better now and they should consider it. Yeah, yeah. I mean, that was one of the comments that the surgeon, it was Orbis International, that does this work. And he said it's, you know, part of the hesitation people have is because they hear about it from their friends and family when it doesn't go well. And so part of what Orbus does is trained. They're training surgeons. They're doing a small incision surgery and it's something you can do with very minimal equipment and a huge improvement. You don't need stitches. And so that, you know, word spreads, like, oh, that actually works because there was a patient there who's like,
严重近视，无论出于什么原因，戴隐形眼镜不舒服，不想做激光手术，他们要求直接把晶状体取出来换个新的。就像他们没有白内障，但他们没有白内障。他们没有白内障。他们只是想要，想要通过这些镜片获得的奇妙视力。所以白内障，这有点令人困惑，因为人们认为它是一个独立于晶状体的东西。但晶状体随着你年龄的增长，会变得浑浊、黑暗和坚硬。整个晶状体被称为白内障。他们把整个东西拿出来，换上一个新的、清晰的、可爱的、人造的晶状体，但这并不是一夜之间实现的，你知道，在60年代，那就像你要在医院住八天，这是一个带有缝线的大切口，人们会躺在床上用沙袋把头部固定在原位，
you know, through a translator said, I had heart surgery a few years ago, and I didn't hesitate on that, but I put off having this cataract operation for a long time because it, you know, it just, it didn't always go well, but these days it's pretty amazing. Yeah, yeah. And one of the things that was so remarkable is knowing that before they actually knew how to put good lenses in, if the cataracts was bad enough, they would just take out the lens and use glasses to be the lens at that point. And it was, it's so much of an improvement just to have the cloudy lens out of the way. Yeah. And way way back, you know, in the 1700s, I mean, couching, it was called couching, comes from the French to lie down, secouche. And so they
手术往往不太顺利，医生不会让人们做这个手术，直到他们老得多，因为他们想等到你的视力变得如此糟糕，以至于即使是一点点改善你也会感恩戴德。是的，但现在，呃，人们对它的满意度比以前更高了。是的。在书中，你实际上去了蒙古，向那些生活在平原上、因此眼睛因阳光照射而受损的人们推广白内障手术，并试图鼓励他们接受这项手术，
would just stick a probe. And then we just like sit down here and I have this probe, but I'm going to stick it in your eye. And they would push, they get the, like push the lens down to the bottom of the eyeball and hold it there. There was one 12th century medical manual that recommended holding it there for four or five our fathers. And you would definitely want somebody saying four or five are fathers if they've got a pointy object in your eye holding down your lens. But then, yeah, suddenly light can come through and hit the retina and you're not able to focus on things. You need super thick glasses, but you can now see. You're not blind because some of those cataract, if you let a cataract go long enough, you're, you're functionally blind, you know.
告诉他们现在这个手术更好了，他们应该考虑一下。是的，是的。我的意思是，这是外科医生（奥比斯国际组织，他们做这项工作）的一条评论。他说，你知道，人们犹豫的部分原因是因为他们从朋友和家人那里听到过手术不顺利的经历。所以奥比斯的一部分工作是培训。他们在培训外科医生。他们正在做微创手术，这是一种可以用极少设备完成且有巨大改善的手术。你不需要缝线。所以，你知道，消息传开了，就像，哦，这确实管用，因为那里有一个病人，他通过翻译说，
Yeah. So your books are super funny and every other sort of, you know, paragraph is a joke. And there's occasionally, there's, you know, like a joke that is so inappropriate, it makes me laugh, that's so inappropriate that I exclaim out loud. I'll go, Mary Roach. And sometimes I'll go, Mary Francis Roach, I'll, like, invent a middle name for you. Mary Abigail Roach. Did you actually say a phlebotomist glory hole or something? Thank you for noticing that one.
我几年前做过心脏手术，当时我没有犹豫，但我推迟了很长时间才做这个白内障手术，因为它，你知道，它并不总是那么顺利，但现在这相当惊人。是的，是的。令人惊奇的事情之一是，在他们真正知道如何放入好的晶状体之前，如果白内障足够严重，他们就会直接取出晶状体，用眼镜来充当当时的晶状体。仅仅是把浑浊的晶状体移开，就是一个巨大的改善。是的。而且很久很久以前，你知道，在1700年代，我是说，拨障术（Couching），它被称为拨障术，这个词源于法语的“躺下”（se coucher）。所以他们
I mean, I was just, I was first of all fascinated by the fact that the early blood banks that, you know, that people were so squeamish about blood that they'd sit down at this, there'd be a wall with holes cut in it and they'd stick their arm through. They'd never have to see the phlebotomist who's drawing the blood. They'd never have to see their own blood coming out in a tube. I was like, oh, my God, it's the lobotomy glory. Is that inappropriate? I don't know. Well, there's, there's, I exclaimed out loud in invoking your middle name, your fake, your fake middle name many, many times just going like, oh my goodness, Mary.
只会伸出一根探针。然后我们就像“坐在这里，我拿着这根探针，我要把它扎进你的眼里”。他们会推，让晶状体推到眼球底部并把它固定在那里。12世纪的一本医学手册建议把它固定在那里默念四到五遍“我们的主”（天主教祈祷文）。如果有人拿着尖锐物体在你的眼里固定你的晶状体，你肯定希望有人在念四到五遍“我们的主”。但随后，是的，光线突然可以穿透并射中视网膜，虽然你无法对焦。你需要超级厚的眼镜，但你现在能看见了。你没有瞎，因为如果你让白内障发展足够长的时间，你就会在功能上失明，你知道的。
My goodness, Mary. Mary. Anastasia Roach. How could you say such a thing? You sound like my mother. Mary Catherine Roach. That part of the book is so delightful. I was wondering, like, how you.
是的。所以你的书超级搞笑，几乎每隔一个段落就是一个笑话。而且偶尔会有那种非常不恰当的笑话，让我大笑，非常不恰当以至于我忍不住大声惊呼。我会说：“玛丽·罗奇。”有时我会说：“玛丽·弗朗西斯·罗奇，”我会像这样给你编造一个中间名。玛丽·阿比盖尔·罗奇。你真的说出过“静脉采血员的光荣洞”之类的话吗？谢谢你注意到那个。
You know, I know you as just a funny person, it is interesting to me that you write the funniest books I've read. And also they are rigorous factual explorations of things. Is this a natural thing for you? Is this a thing that you're interested in this and this is who you are and so for this? Or is there an aspect to this where you think this is the way to explore this type of thing? Yeah. I think it's the former. I think science in the human body are endlessly interesting. and strange, and I've always been surprised by the things that I learn when I sit down with somebody who knows this stuff, because I didn't pay any attention in high school to science at all. I took the gut science, you know, not the advanced, what is it, the AP science. Apparently that was a better teacher. Anyway, I just didn't pay any attention. I thought science was boring. But, you know, fast forward to when I started writing, and I You know, I was writing for Discover Magazine because they'd asked me to.
我是说，我当时，首先我被这样一个事实迷住了：早期的血库，人们对血感到如此恐慌，以至于他们会坐在一个墙上有洞的墙壁前，把手臂伸过去。他们永远不必看到抽血的静脉采血员。他们永远不必看到自己的血流进管子里。我当时想，哦，天哪，这就是静脉切开术的光荣洞。这不合适吗？我不知道。嗯，有，我大声惊呼，搬出了你的中间名，你虚构的中间名，很多很多次，嘴里喊着：“哦，天哪，玛丽。”
And I went, oh, holy shit, science. It's kind of cool. The human body. It's like another planet. I think it's interesting. But I think that it stems from my insecurity. I'm always picturing, and the humor that is, I'm picturing someone reading thinking, like I did. Oh, science, this is kind of boring.
“天哪，玛丽。玛丽·阿纳斯塔西娅·罗奇。你怎么能说出这样的话？”听起来像我妈。玛丽·凯瑟琳·罗奇。书的那一部分太让人高兴了。我想知道，你是怎么……
I don't think I want to read this book. So I'm like just running as fast as I can, dancing as fast as I can, make it interesting. Stay with me. I'm not going to be boring. It's not going to be a slog like science was for me in high school. I want you to stay here with me. So that's, I think, a large part of it. Also, it's just more fun for me to write that way. I kind of, I entertain myself that way. And if it's not entertaining for me, forget about it. It has to be fun for me. when we come back Mary tells us about her dreams of having flowing locks of hair on her leg
你知道，我只知道你是个有趣的人，这对我来说很有趣，你写出了我读过最搞笑的书。同时它们也是对事物的严谨事实探索。这是一种自然而然的事情吗？这是你感兴趣的事物，这就是本来的你，所以才写成这样吗？还是说，这里面有一种因素让你觉得这是探索这种事情的方式？是的。我想是前者。我认为科学和人体有着无穷无尽的趣味和奇异之处，每当我跟一个懂这些的人坐在一起时，我总是会被我学到的东西惊艳到，因为我在高中时根本不关注科学。我上的是“普通科学”，而不是高级的……那叫什么来着，AP科学。显然那是个更好的老师。不管怎样，我就是没注意听。我以为科学很无聊。但是，快进到我开始写作的时候，你知道，我为《发现》杂志写作，因为他们邀请了我。
more after the break we're back with Mary Roach so in your books I think I first recognize this in your second book Bonk where you have sex with your husband and an MRI and have people take pictures of it
休息之后还有更多内容。我们欢迎玛丽·罗奇回归。那么在你的书里，我想我第一次注意到是在你的第二本著作《邦克》里，你在核磁共振仪里和你的丈夫发生了性关系，还让人拍了照片
like the insides of your bodies but you're weekly game for things. It's a huge part of what makes your books so fun. Can you talk about the things that you participated in for this book? Sure. I have to point out, though, that was, in fact, ultrasound, which is so much more embarrassing. At least with an MRI, you have some privacy. Ultrasound, there's a dude in a white coat holding an ultrasound wand to my belly, and Ed is behind me, and that is a really embarrassing afternoon. So, moving on. Yeah, for this, let's see, for this book, yeah, I spent some time in an old Emerson Iron Lung, a holdover from the polio era back before there was a vaccine.
就像你身体内部一样，但你对各种事情都跃跃欲试。这是让你的书如此有趣的一个重要部分。你能谈谈为了这本书你都参与了哪些事情吗？当然。不过我必须指出，那其实是超声波，这就尴尬多了。至少在核磁共振时，你还有一些隐私。做超声波时，一个穿着白大褂的家伙拿着超声探头贴着我的肚子，爱德就在我身后，那真是一个极其尴尬的下午。所以，我们继续。是的，为了这个，让我想想，为了这本书，是的，我在一个老旧的爱默生铁肺里待了一段时间，那是小儿麻痹症流行前、也就是还没有疫苗的时代留下的产物。
You know, not everybody who got polio had to be in an iron lung, but if you had a bad enough case of paralytic polio, your diaphragm and your rib muscles were out of commission. so you can't breathe. So, and I wanted to get at, like, what does that feel like to have a machine breathe for you? And actually breathe like you because an iron lung, unlike the ventilators in the ICU today, which are positive pressure ventilation, it's like your lung is a party balloon. It's being blown in there. Whereas negative pressure, which is an iron lung, it's done by vacuum. Like you pull out the air out of the tube and then,
你知道，并不是每个得小儿麻痹症的人都必须进铁肺，但如果你的麻痹性小儿麻痹症病情足够严重，你的横膈膜和肋骨肌肉就会停止工作，所以你无法呼吸。因此，我想弄清楚，让一台机器代你呼吸是什么感觉？而且呼吸方式要像你一样，因为铁肺不像今天重症监护室里的呼吸机那是正压通气，它就像你的肺是一个派对气球，气是从外面吹进去的。而负压，也就是铁肺，是通过真空完成的，就像你把空气从管子里抽出来，然后，
the lung, the rib cage expands, and that pulls in the air. Anyway, so I found a guy who's had a iron lung. His wife had died about a year before, and somebody told me, because I was asking around. And so there's this guy, Mark Randolph, who lived in Kansas City, said yes, you can come to Kansas City and try out my deceased wife's iron lung. Now that I'm saying it, it sounds like a really weird thing to ask somebody. But as you say, I'm game. And he was game. And so I got there and they are like two people who he'd recruited to help because it's not simple. It's similar to an MRI in that there's a bed that rolls out and then rolls back in. But then you have to get your head through that opening. And it's like this weird.
肺，胸腔扩张，这就把空气吸进去了。总之，我找到了一个用过铁肺的人。他的妻子在大约一年前去世了，有人告诉我，因为我一直在四处打听。于是有这么一个人，住在堪萨斯城的马克·兰道夫，他说，你可以来堪萨斯城，试试我已故妻子的铁肺。现在说出来，这听起来像是对别人提出的一个非常奇怪的要求。但正如你所说，我很大胆。他也很大胆。于是我到了那里，他们有两个人，他招募来帮忙，因为这并不简单。它有点像核磁共振，里面有一张床，可以滑出来然后滑回去。但接着你必须把头穿过那个开口。这感觉就像是个奇怪的
Your head's coming through. And there's people are kind of holding the head like it's like they're obstetricians giving birth to you through this hole. It's very, very weird. So I did that. I did that. Like this is something that his wife sort of went through every single night for hours and hours at a time. But how long did you last in the iron? Yeah, about nine minutes.
你的头伸出来了。然后有人扶着头，就像产科医生通过这个洞把你生出来一样。非常非常奇怪。所以我照做了。我照做了。就像这是他妻子差不多每天晚上都要经历几个小时的事情。但是你在铁肺里坚持了多久？是的，大约九分钟。
Because I had planned to, I wanted to spend the night in it. But one thing about it in order to have. to create a vacuum it has to be a seal has to be tight you can't have any air leaks that means that the collar around your neck has to be tight
因为我原本计划，我想在里面过夜。但关于它的一点是，为了产生真空，它必须是一个密封，必须非常紧密，不能有任何漏气，这意味着你脖子周围的领圈必须很紧
uncomfortably tight and so it was this weird also he had it turned way up because that's what Mona his late wife had needed so but I didn't need that so I got in there
紧得让人不舒服，所以这很奇怪，而且他把它开得很大，因为那是莫娜，他已故的妻子所需要的，所以但我并不需要那样，所以我进去了
so it was this weird thing where I was breathing like deeply and luxuriantly like but at the same time feeling like I was being strangled so it was this weird combination of like you're breathing in a more relaxed way than you ever have and yet you feel as though you're being strangled and I asked Jane the woman who had sort of set me up
所以这是一种奇怪的感觉，我呼吸得很深、很惬意，但同时又感觉自己快要被勒死了，所以这是一种奇怪的组合，就像你在以比以往任何时候都更放松的方式呼吸，但又感觉自己仿佛正在被勒死。我问简，那个帮我安排这一切的女士
and I said for Mona what was it what was it like how could she stand it and she said well it was a situation like this she had chronic pulmonary disease so it was a struggle for her to breathe She said, at the end of the day, she was so happy to get in it. She'd been breathing all day, struggling, never quite feeling like she was getting enough air. So she was always happy to get in it at the end of the night and so happy to get out of it in the morning. Yeah. So like that.
我说，对于莫娜来说，那是什么样的？她怎么能忍受呢？她说，情况是这样的，她有慢性肺病，所以呼吸对她来说是一种挣扎。她说，一天结束时，她太高兴能进去了。她一整天都在呼吸，在挣扎，从没有真正觉得吸入了足够的空气。所以她总是在一天结束时很高兴能进去，早上又很高兴能出来。是的。就像那样。
You also, when you were researching hair replacement and hair shaft replacement, you proposed the idea of them harvesting a part of your hair and implanting it onto your leg. Yes. And I had a reason for that. I had a good reason, Roman. I wanted to demonstrate for myself. And going forward, maybe people who came to a book event, I wanted to demonstrate donor dominance. And that is, and with a hair transplant, if somebody has male pattern baldness, okay, they've got hair grown on the sides and the back, because hair there isn't affected by testosterone. It doesn't care. But the hair on the top, is sensitive to it. So if you take hair from the back and you put it up top, donor dominance, the donor site rules. So the hair stays. So I wanted to take some head hair because I was actually donating some follicular units for some research down the road at a stem cell place. I said, while you're there, can you take a couple units and transplant them to my leg? Because I just thought it would be cool to have like a few strands of long flowing hair on my calf. Just, you know, not a lot, maybe three or four.
当你在研究头发移植和毛干移植时，你还提出了这样一个想法：割取你的一部分头发并将其植入你的腿上。是的。我这么做是有理由的。我有一个充分的理由，罗曼。我想向自己证明这一点。而且展望未来，也许来到图书活动的人们，我想展示供区优势。也就是说，在头发移植中，如果某人有男性型脱发，好吧，他们两侧和后脑勺都长着头发，因为那里的头发不受睾酮的影响。它不在乎。但头顶的头发对它很敏感。所以如果你把后脑勺的头发拿来放到头顶上，供区优势，供区说了算。所以头发留了下来。所以我想拿一些头皮头发，因为我实际上是要为以后干细胞机构的一些研究捐赠一些毛囊单位。我说，当你在那里时，你能拿几个单位并把它们移植到我的腿上吗？因为我只是觉得在小腿上长出几缕长而飘逸的头发会很酷。只是，你知道，不多，也许三四根。
And I could show people. I could talk about donor dominance and I could roll up my pant leg and go, look, look here. This is what I'm talking about. And sadly, they didn't take. And that's what the surgeon was, he's kind of skeptical. He's like, you know, the leg is a much weaker. There's not as much blood supply to the cat. compared with the scalp.
我可以向人们展示。我可以谈论供区优势，我可以卷起裤腿说，看，看这里。这就是我所说的。遗憾的是，它们没有存活。这就是外科医生的态度，他有点怀疑。他说，你知道，腿要弱得多。小腿的血液供应没有头皮那么充足。
So I don't know if that's going to work. But I made them try it anyway. The woman who, Galena, the woman who does most of the transplanting, she was so not interested in it. He didn't want to tell her. He's like, Galena is done taking the follicle. She goes, okay, you're all set. And the doctor, Dr. Shafu, he goes,
所以我不知道这是否行得通。但我还是让他们试了。那个女人，加利纳，那个负责大部分移植工作的女人，她对这个毫无兴趣。他不想告诉她。他说，加利纳已经取好毛囊了。她说，好了，一切就绪。然后医生，沙富医生说，
um, Galena, she was talking about wanting to take this. so home hairs and putting him on her leg and yeah anyway we convinced her but it but it didn't take in the end no I'm so disappointed I mean this interaction you know makes me think of another thing which is you know often you are writing about stuff that is pretty sensitive you know stuff to do with our bodies medical stuff that maybe someone might be hesitant to talk to you for for whatever reason and sometimes if you find someone who won't talk to you that's based here in the United States, you'll, like, fly to Russia to find someone to talk with you. I will do that, yes.
嗯，加利纳，她一直在说想把这些头发拿回家，然后放到她的腿上，是的，无论如何我们说服了她，但最终它没有存活，不，我太失望了。我是说，这次互动，你知道，让我想起了另一件事，那就是，你知道你经常在写一些相当敏感的事情，你知道，跟我们的身体有关的事情，医学方面的事情，可能有人会出于某种原因犹豫是否要跟你谈谈，有时如果你发现某人在美国不肯跟你谈，你就会，比如说，飞到俄罗斯去找人跟你谈。我会这么做的，是的。
And more and more I've noticed that you're probably reaching folks who know your work, and they welcome you even though what they do is pretty sensitive. And in the book, Replaceable You, you talk about this organization called Core, and you kind of have to convince them that your domestication of their work would actually be really helpful to their mission. Could you talk about your role in pulling back the curtain on things that seem? scary or gruesome? The example that you gave has to do
而且我越来越注意到，你可能正在接触那些了解你的作品的人，他们欢迎你，尽管他们所做的事情相当敏感。在书中，在《可替代的你》里，你谈到了一个名为Core的组织，你必须说服他们，你对他们工作的通俗化其实对他们的使命真的很有帮助。你能谈谈你在揭开那些看似可怕或可怕的事情的面纱时所扮演的角色吗？你举的例子与此有关
it was tissue donation and that is as opposed to organ donation. You can also donate tissue which is bone, skin, tendon, ligaments and when I wrote stiff I wanted to cover
那是组织捐献，这与器官捐献相对。你还可以捐献组织，也就是骨骼、皮肤、肌腱、韧带，当我写《尸体》时，我想涵盖
that but no one at these places would get back to me or return my calls. And I understand why people are hesitant to have someone come in because I've seen it. You know, and I described it kind of like a Francis Bacon painting. For me, it's just kind of amazing to see.
这一点，但这些地方没有人给我回信或回电话。我理解为什么人们不愿意让别人进来，因为我见过了。你知道，我把它形容得有点像弗朗西斯·培根的画。对我来说，看到这一幕真是太神奇了。
And I could say that the way they take skin from the back, so no one will see there. And from the lower, they don't take anything from the face. They take things from the legs. And it's done. And then they kind of stitch it back up. It's like opening up a tamale almost, pulling the stuff out. they're putting the skin back and stitching it up. And it's, I guess, in a way, you know, it is kind of a gruesome thing to see,
我可以这样说，他们从后背取皮肤的方式，所以没有人会在那里看到。还有从下半部分，他们不会从脸上取任何东西。他们从腿上取。这就完成了。然后他们把它缝合起来。这几乎就像打开一个玉米粉蒸肉，把东西拉出来，把皮肤放回去再缝起来。我想在某种程度上，你知道，这确实是一件看起来有点可怕的事情，
but no more so than witnessing some kinds of surgery. You know, ultimately it's surgery. And unlike surgery, that this patient, in quotes, doesn't feel any pain. There's no downside. You know what I mean? It's all benefit. They don't care. They're just doing something good.
但并不比目睹某些手术更甚。你知道，归根结底它是手术。而且与手术不同的是，这个所谓的“病人”感觉不到任何疼痛。没有任何不利因素。你知道我的意思吗？全都是好处。他们不在乎。他们只是在做一件好事。
and it doesn't matter what it looks like in someone's imagination. So I kind of just want, I find that if you can demystify this and just say, yeah, it sounds kind of gruesome. This is what it's like. And my hope is always that I'm not putting people off. Either organ donation or tissue donation, you can end up helping, I think it's 75 people with one person's tissue. You know, the bones are used for little spacers and spine.
而且它在人们的想象中看起来是什么样并不重要。所以我只是想，我发现如果你能消除这种神秘感，只是说，是的，听起来有点可怕。这就是它的样子。我的希望总是，我没有把人们吓退。无论是器官捐献还是组织捐献，一个人的组织最终可以帮助，我想是75人。你知道，骨头被用作脊柱手术中的小垫片，
surgery, the skin is used as sort of biodressing for people who have had serious burns and there's all kinds of reconstruction that can be done with this tissue. So it's a really good thing to do. And I
皮肤被用作重度烧伤患者的生物敷料，并且可以用这种组织进行各种重建。所以这是一件非常好的事情。并且我
completely understand why they're called OPEO's organ procurement organizations. I get why they're wary of somebody coming in because if you chose to you could make it sound really bad. I'm like, oh, now they're pulling out this, he's holding this guy leg and there's blood here and I'm like yeah you could make it sound bad if you wanted to but I
完全理解为什么他们被称为OPO器官获取组织。我明白为什么他们对别人的造访心存戒备，因为如果你选择这样做，你可以把它说得很糟糕。我会想，哦，现在他们正在掏出这个，他正抓着这个家伙的腿，这里有血，我在想，是的，如果你想的话，你可以把它说得很糟糕，但我
I just feel like if you act like you have something to hide people think you have something to hide how is working on this book changed the way you think about yourself and your own body like are you like would you would you get a pig organ put in your body would you know like how does it I don't know how does it change your oh yeah I mean how cool it would be cool I know I'd be like if If you can save my life by throwing a pig heart in there and it's going to actually work for a while, maybe long enough at least for me to get a human transplant, absolutely. And what a cool thing to be able to say at a cocktail party. I've got a pig heart in there.
我只是觉得，如果你表现得像有什么不可告人的秘密，人们就会认为你有什么不可告人的秘密。写这本书如何改变了你对你自己和你的身体的看法？比如说，你会不会，你会不会把猪的器官放进你的体内？你知道，这怎么，我不知道这怎么改变了你的，哦，是的，我是说，多酷啊，这会很酷，我知道我会像，如果如果你能通过往里面扔一颗猪心脏来救我的命，而且它真的能管用一段时间，也许至少能撑到我得到人类移植，绝对可以。能在鸡尾酒会上说出这样一件酷事是多么棒啊。我身体里有一颗猪心脏。
I don't know. I always have trouble coming up with interesting small talk. Oh, I find that very hard to believe, Mary. If I could say, you know what, I've got to. I have a friend, Clark, who has a third. kidney. And he would sort of bring that up at parties. And I was all kind of jealous. Man, I wish I had a third kidney. I wish I had third kidney. I mean, I could lie, I suppose. Too honest. But while we're on the subject, what is the deal with pigs? Like, they're kind of the
我不知道。我总是很难想出有趣的闲聊话题。哦，我觉得这很难相信，玛丽。如果我能说，你知道吗，我必须。我有一个朋友克拉克，他有第三个肾。他会在派对上提起这个。我当时有点嫉妒。天哪，我要是有第三个肾就好了。我要是有第三个肾就好了。我是说，我可以撒谎，我想。太诚实了。但既然我们说到这儿了，猪是怎么回事？比如说，它们有点像
go-to for human replacement parts, you know, like as an organism. Like, what is it about pigs that makes them good for this? I'm glad you asked. Because I have a whole section on that. And you can blame Hormel. Hormel back in the, oh, I think it might start in the 40s, 40s, 50s era. I'm terrible with dates. But the Mayo Foundation, which is the research arm of the Mayo Clinic, and the Hormel Institute, which is the research arm of pork, they work together to miniaturize pigs in order to create a lab animal that would have organs of approximately the same size.
人类替换部件的首选，你知道的，作为一个有机体。比如说，猪有什么特别之处，使它们很适合做这个？我很高兴你问了。因为我有一整章都在讲这个。你可以怪荷美尔。荷美尔在，哦，我想它可能始于40年代，40年代、50年代的时代。我对日期一窍不通。但梅奥基金会，也就是梅奥诊所的研究机构，以及荷美尔研究所，也就是猪肉的研究机构，他们合作将猪小型化，以便培育出器官大小相近的实验动物。
eyes, but that also wouldn't be so loud and rambunctious as a full-grown pig. That's a large, loud animal to have running around a lab or anywhere in a facility, research facility. So they started breeding them smaller and breeding them for the purpose of studying various surgical procedures. The other thing with pig hearts, pigs are, this one researcher described them as almost a caricature of an obese human because they get atherosclerosis,
但同时又不会像成年猪那样吵闹和难以管教。对于实验室或研究设施中的任何地方来说，这都是一个体型庞大、叫声吵闹的动物。所以他们开始培育体型更小的猪，并以研究各种外科手术为目的来培育它们。关于猪心脏的另一件事，猪是，一位研究人员将其描述为肥胖人类的漫画版，因为它们会患上动脉粥样硬化，
they have heart problems, pigs that are being raised on farms don't get a lot of exercise and they eat garbage. So they're a very apt animal to use for studying heart disease. But the other thing going on here is, I mean, obviously a primate
它们有心脏问题，在农场里养大的猪没有很多运动而且吃垃圾。所以它们是非常适合用来研究心脏病的动物。但这里发生的另一件事是，我的意思是，显然后长类动物
might be a better fit, I mean, better, closer match, but there are ethical issues and also zoonoses, like diseases can transfer more readily between two primates than between a... I mean, it's still an issue with pigs, but less so. So there was all of that going on. Yeah, yeah. So they're close, but not too close.
可能更合适，我是说更好、更接近的匹配，但存在伦理问题，还有人畜共患病，比如疾病在灵长类动物之间比在...我的意思是，对猪来说这仍然是个问题，但没那么严重。所以这一切都在发生。是的，是的。所以它们很接近，但又不是太接近。
And there's also, like, agricultural research can push things forward when medical research is not, like, always funded to the best of our ability. Yeah, right. Yeah. And I think, I'm sure on some level, the hormal people were like, Oh, another way to sell pigs. Lab animals. Exactly. I have to say, I did not speak to anybody from the Hormel Institute,
而且还有，农业研究可以在医学研究资金并非总是最充足的时候推动事情向前发展。是的，没错。是的。而且我想，我敢肯定在某种程度上，荷美尔的人会想，哦，这是卖猪的另一种方式。实验动物。没错。我得说，我没有跟荷美尔研究所的任何人交谈过，
as I don't think they exist anymore. But anyway, they published a whole lot of papers. About pigs. Yeah, the whole miniaturization of the pig project went on for some time. Did you come away from all this research thinking that maybe in our quest to have normal function for our worn-out damaged bodies, we over-emphasize this idea of this integrated whole, like a quote-unquote normal body, and maybe we should be more open to a like a variety of solutions. Yeah, yeah.
因为我觉得他们不复存在了。但不管怎样，他们发表了大量的论文。关于猪的。是的，猪小型化项目进行了好一阵子。你从所有这些研究中得出的结论是，也许在我们追求让疲惫受损的身体恢复正常功能的过程中，我们过分强调了这种整体整合的观念，比如所谓的“正常身体”，也许我们应该对各种各样的解决方案持更开放的态度？是的，是的。
I think that it would be great if people were drawn to whatever works best without being hung up by what does it look like and how much will I, how will I not look like everyone else? But, you know, part of that is like if it's in, the other side of that is if it's inside you and it's incorporated in you, you don't have to think about it. You don't see it. You don't have to change its batteries. You don't have to, it becomes part of you and you can just live your life normally. So it's not just that bias for wholeness. It's also wanting to just be able to go through your life without thinking about that part. You know, we are happiest when we are unaware of all our parts and what they're doing. We just want them to do their thing and be invisible. So, you know, anytime you externalize a piece of yourself, it's always there, you know? Yeah, yeah. Well, the book is so good.
我认为，如果人们能被最管用的方法所吸引，而不会纠结于它看起来是什么样、我会有什么不同、或者我怎么才能不像别人，那就太好了。但你知道，这其中一部分是，另一方面，如果它在你的内心深处并与你融为一体，你就不必去思考它。你看不见它。你不需要给它换电池。你不需要……它成为了你的一部分，你就可以正常地生活。所以这不仅仅是对完整的偏爱。这也意味着想要能够过好自己的生活，而不必去想那一部分。你知道，当我们对所有的部分及其运作方式一无所知时，我们是最快乐的。我们只希望它们做好它们该做的事并保持隐形。所以，你知道，任何时候当你把一部分自我外化时，它就总是会在那里，对吧？是的，是的。这本书真是太棒了。
Your books are so good. I enjoy talking to you so much. So thank you for doing this. I really appreciate it. Thank you so much for doing this. It was fabulous. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Medina Gleason and edited by Chris for Johnson. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Rieau.
你的书太棒了。我非常喜欢和你交谈。所以非常感谢你接受采访。我真的很感激。非常感谢你接受采访。这太棒了。《99% Invisible》本周由雅各布·麦地那·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）制作，克里斯·福·约翰逊（Chris for Johnson）编辑。由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·里欧（Swan Rieau）创作。
Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kirk Colestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
凯西·图（Kathy, too）也是我们的执行制片人。柯克·科尔斯特德（Kirk Colestead）是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barubei）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉谢马顿（Lashemadon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99% 的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。位于美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode, including many, many with Mary Roach at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，还有过去的每一集节目，包括许多与玛丽·罗奇（Mary Roach）合作的节目，都在 99PI.org。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。